you do not do not have Kim Kardashian's
mystery illness revealed I'm so relieved
the pain is gonna come and go sometimes
but I can manage it and this is not
gonna stop me on Sunday night's Keeping
Up with the Kardashians
we saw Kim get an important update
regarding her lupus scare the doctor
confirmed she does not have the
debilitating autoimmune disease and you
do not do not smoke arthritis because
psoriasis and there's nothing there
right now Kim found out the news after
she went into her doctor for an
ultrasound on her hands to get some
clarity on what was happening with her
body following weeks of severe joint
pain fatigue and a blood test that
tested positive for lupus antibodies my
blood test results were so scary but
these ultrasounds will really determine
what's going on with me ét recently sat
down with Kim since the taping of the
show and finding out her diagnosis where
she updated us on her current health
status and you've opened up about a big
health scare and perhaps depression or
anxiety that can come along with it how
do you have those difficult
conversations with the kids and I mean
is northe who's six if I'm not mistaken
is she even old enough to kind of
comprehend like mommy's going through a
tough time right now yeah no I
definitely keep that away from the kids
I think they're just too young to really
realize if I'm in pain it was really
hard cuz I couldn't pick up the kids for
a while because I had a lot of pain in
my hands so until I figured it out of
what was really going on I really needed
to just like take a break from lifting
the baby and that was really hard for me
my baby Chicago who's like a big baby
you know she's not light but I was
really worried that I had my baby coming
my baby boy and I just thought it was
gonna be really hard for me so luckily I
got it all under wraps but when you do
have a diagnosis or you get tested for
something and you get a result that you
weren't expecting you definitely get in
your head and you start for a second you
kind of get this little depression of
okay what are all the possibilities that
can happen what's my life gonna look
like I really want to be active for my
kids and so it triggers something but
then I really had to get myself together
because I do have kids okay I do have
you know a family that I have to just be
positive and get it together for so I
believe no matter what's going on in
your life you can't take that time to
grieve for a second no matter what it is
what you're grieving feel those feelings
and then figure out how to be positive
about it because it's not going to
change so there's no point in being
depressed and staying in that headspace
but I felt it for a minute
good things to take away from that then
you're healthy now everything's okay
everything's okay I want a medication
now so everything seems to be fine for
right now and I'm just rolling with it
day by day
[Music]